من الدعم العسكري عن بعد الى نشر مدربين
ومستشارين عسكريين على الارض وانشاء
برنامج تدريب عسكري بقياده بريطانيا داخل
اوكرانيا بدلا من كونه في القواعد
العسكريه التابعه لبعض دول حلف شمال
الاطلسي يقول وزير الدفاع البريطاني جراند
ان غرب اوكرانيا لن يكون بوابه للمدربين
العسكريين فحسب وانما ايضا لشركات الدفاع
البريطانيه يدعو شابس هذه الشركات لانشاء
مصانع اسلحه في اوكرانيا يستدرك رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ريشيسوناك تصريحات وزير
الدفاعه بالقول انه لا خطط حاليا لارسال
جنود بريطانيين في مهمه تدريبيه الى
اوكرانيا وان مقترحات وزير الدفاع رؤى
للمدى البعيد لا للصراع الحالي فحتى الان
ينقى حلفائك في الغرب عن ان تطا اقدام
جنودهم ارض المعركه في اوكرانيا تجنبا لاي
صراع مباشر مع روسيا لكن حديث المسؤولين
في لندن يمكن قراءته في سياق سياسه تبنتها
بريطانيا منذ بدء الحرب بالتقدم خطوه على
الدول الغربيه الداعمه لكيف
فمع بدايه الحرب اعلن رئيس الوزراء الاسبق
فورد جونسون صراحه ان ما تريده لندن وتسعى
اليه هو هزيمه الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين مهما كلف الثمن والمملكه المتحده من
ابرز الداعمين فمنذ بدايه الحرب تجاوزت
دعم البريطاني ثمانيه مليارات دولار وقد
تلقى نحو 30 الف مجند اوكراني تدريبا
عسكريا في اطار برنامج التدريب الذي تقوده
المملكه المتحده منذ عام 2022 في مارس
الماضي فاجات بريطانيا العالم بان كانت
السباقه قبل اوروبا والولايات المتحده
بارسال اربعه عشره من دباباتها المتطوره
اثنين الى الجيش الاوكراني تلاهوا قرار
مفاجئ اخر في مايو الماضي بتزويد كييف
بصواريخ ستورم شادو وطائرات من دون طيار
هجوميه بعيده المدى ومشاركه بريطانيا في
تدريب القوات الاوكرانيه بدات فعليا من
روسيا شبه جزيره القرم ضمن ما يعرف بعمليه
اوربيتال المشتركه بين البلدين منذ عام
2015 اذ اشرفت القوات المسلحه
والاستخبارات البريطانيه معا على تدريب 22
الف جندي اوكراني في ذلك الوقت يقول
الرئيس الاوكراني السابق في تروبورشينكو
انه ورث جيشا متهالكا عندما تولى السلطه
عام 2014 لكن هذه القوات تبدلت احوالها
بفضل المساعدات والدعم الغربي
[موسيقى]